AND LAURA GRANT JUST TRYING TO
RUIN YOUR HOLIDAYS.
FIRST, BIDEN’S FALSE PROPHETS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IN THE NEW TESTAMENT BOOK OF
MATTHEW, WARNS THAT WE SHOULD
BEWARE OF FALSE PROPHETS WHO
COME TO YOU IN SHEEP’S
CLOTHING.
IN POLITICS AND IN THE MEDIA,
THERE ARE PLENTY OF FALSE
PROPHETS WHO TRY TO SELL YOU ON
POLICIES THAT DELIVER RUIN
INSTEAD OF RESULT.
ENTER "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
OVER THE WEEKEND, IT PUBLISHED
AN EDITORIAL CALLED "LET’S TALK
ABOUT HIGHER WAGES."
THE NATION IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DESPERATELY
NEED TO REPLACE THE TIRED STORY
THAT TAX CUTS DRIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
BUT WHEN YOU READ ON AND THE
EDITORIAL, YOU SEE THAT THE
GENIUSES AT THE TIME HAVE NO
CLUE ABOUT WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN
NEXT.
HERE IS THEIR CONCLUSION.
THE NATION’S LAWS, SOCIAL NORMS,
AND PATTERNS OF DAILY LIFE HAVE
ALL BEEN REVISED AND RECENT
DECADES TO FACILITATE THE
SUPPRESSION OF WAGE GROWTH.
EXACTLY.
BUT THAT’S WHAT WE POPULACE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
THE QUESTION IS -- WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT?
AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ONLY
PRACTICAL SUGGESTION IS THAT WE
BEGIN BY TELLING BETTER STORIES
ABOUT THE WAY THE ECONOMY WORKS.
THANKS, "NEW YORK TIMES."
I’M SURE WORKERS EVERYWHERE THIS
TIME OF YEAR ARE GOING TO RUN TO
YOUR WEBSITE AND POUR OVER EVERY
TWISTED TALE YOU TELL.
WHAT’S MORE MARK ABOUT THIS
EDITORIAL IS THAT THE WORDS
"PRESIDENT TRUMP" APPEAR NOWHERE
IN IT.
AMERICAN WORKERS TRUSTED HIM TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS FOR THEM.
FURTHERMORE, AND THE FIRST TERM,
HE SUCCEEDED.
IT JUST BLOWS AWAY EXPECTATIONS.
SPEAK OF THIS IS THE BEST I’VE
EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
>> YOU CAN’T CONTRADICT THAT
THIS IS THE BEST NUMBERS OF OUR
LIVES?
>> GETTING SUPPORT FROM BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
>> HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS DEAL?
NOT JUST FOR ISRAEL FOR THAT
MATTER, BUTER F, BUT FOR THE REG
REGION.
>> PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
IN FACT, IT’S HISTORIC.
>> A NEW NARRATIVE, A NARRATIVE
HOPE AND PROSPERITY.
>> Laura: THE TIMES COMPLAINS
ABOUT WAGE STAGNATION.
BUT THOSE COMPLETES ARE OUT OF
DATE.
WE’VE TOLD YOU MANY TIMES, REAL
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME IN THE
UNITED STATES GREW BY $6,000
FROM 2016 TO 2019.
FORGIVE ME FOR ACTUALLY DEALING
IN FACTS TONIGHT.
THEY INCREASED BY 4%.
SO WE DON’T NEED TO BETTER
STORIES ABOUT WAGES, WE JUST
NEED TO STUDY THE POLICIES THAT
WE PURSUED UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WORKED.
NOW, LUCKY FOR US, IT ONLY TAKES
A BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF ECON
101 TO EXPLAIN THE SUCCESS OF
AMERICA FIRST POLICY.
FOR STARTERS, WAGES ARE THE
PRICE THAT BUSINESSES PAY FOR
LABOR, RED?
LIKE A ANY OTHER PRICE, THEY ARE
DETERMINED BY DEMAND.
THAT MEANS ELIMINATING
UNNECESSARY REGULATIONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ENCOURAGES
AMERICAN BUSINESSES TO HIRE MORE
WORKERS.
THAT’S GOOD, BUT THAT’S NOT
ENOUGH.
WHICH IS WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESTRICTED THE SUPPLY OF LABOR.
HE USED TARIFFS AND TRADE
POLICIES THAT WERE SMART TO MAKE
IT HARDER FOR COMPANIES TO SHIFT
JOBS OFFSHORE.
AND BY ENFORCING IMMIGRATION
LAWS, PUTTING TIGHTER CONTROLS
ON WORK VISAS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
MADE IT HARDER FOR BUSINESSES TO
DRIVE DOWN WAGES FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THESE POLICIES WERE EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL.
THAT WASN’T IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL.
BY FEBRUARY 2020, THE LAST MONTH
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT, THE
U.S. UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS ONLY
3.5%.
UNFORTUNATELY, BIDEN AND HIS
GLOBALISTS WILL TAKE UP IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
JANET YELLEN, CHOICE OF
TREASURY, THERE’S NO REASON TO
BELIEVE HE’S NOT GOING TO FOLLOW
THE SAME GAME PLAN THAT BIDEN
ADVOCATED DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
WHICH IS HIGHER TAXES, MORE
REGULATION, GREATER HOSTILITY
TOWARD BUSINESS.
PUSH FOR LOCKDOWNS, ET CETERA.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THERE’S GOING
TO BE HUGE GIVEAWAYS TO
UNSCRUPULOUS COMPANIES THAT
PREFER NOT TO PAY A DECENT WAGE
TO AMERICANS.
BECAUSE UNDER BIDEN, IT’S GOING
TO BE EASIER TO OFFSHORE JOBS
AND USE ILLEGAL LABOR TO FILL
THE HOLE.
THUS, THEY WILL KILL THE DEMAND
FOR AMERICAN LABOR.
SO THE AVERAGE AMERICAN WORKER
ENDS UP GETTING SHAFTED AGAIN
UNDER BIDEN’S RULES.
NOW, BIDEN IS PICKED AHEAD.
HE PRAYED A LOT ABOUT HER
TONIGHT.
SHE CLAIMS THAT RISING INCOME
INEQUALITY WAS THE CONSEQUENCE
OF DECADES OF CONSERVATIVE
ATTACKS ON WORKERS RIGHTS TO
ORGANIZE AND THAT LABOR UNIONS
ARE A POWERFUL VEHICLE TO MOVE
WORKERS INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS.
AND KEEP THEM THERE.
OKAY, I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
MS. PANDAN.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A UNION GOES
TO MANAGEMENT AND DEMANDS A PAY
RAISE?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN MANAGEMENT
SAYS OKAY, WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
OUR COMPANY TO INDIA THEN, BY.
OF COURSE THE FOCUS ON INCOME
INEQUALITY IS FOOLISH.
BUILDING UP THE MIDDLE CLASS AS
TRUMP DATE IS THE WAY TO GO.
AND BY THE WAY, EVEN IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THEIR STATED INCOME
INEQUALITY, YOU DON’T HELP
BRIDGE THE INCOME INEQUALITY BY
HAMMERING THE MIDDLE CLASS WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT’S HAPPENING IN
PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK.
>> PEOPLE SADDLE LIKE THE
RESTRICTIONS, I HAVE COVID
FATIGUE, HOW COULD YOU SAY I
SHOULDN’T HAVE MORE THAN TEN
PEOPLE IN OUR HOUSE GOES TO MARK
THIS IS WHERE THE SPREAD IS UP
IN FRONT OF.
>> GIVEN THEIR LIBERAL
LEADERSHIP, THESE STATES -- I
FORGET COVID.
PUSH COVID ASIDE FOR A MOMENT.
THESE SHOULD BE WORKER’S
PARADISE?
BUT EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC,
BEFORE ALL THE TALKS OF
LOCKDOWNS AND RESTRICTIONS,
PEOPLE WERE FLEEING NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA.
THEN A MIDDLE CLASS IS VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT.
THERE IS THE RICH AND FAIR AS
EVERYONE ELSE.
NOW CHECK OUT THE EXIT POLLS
AMONG THOSE WHO SAID THE ECONOMY
WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
THEM.
82% OF THOSE VOTERS WENT FOR
TRUMP.
WELL, THESE PHOTOS WERE TO SET
UP AT THE OLD TRADE DEALS, THE
OLD POLICIES THAT GAVE AWAY THE
STORE TO PLACES LIKE EUROPE AND
CHINA.
OF COURSE, BIDEN IS GOING TO
PUSH THE PARTNERSHIP AND THAT IS
DESIGNED TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES TO LAY
OFF WORKERS HERE AND SHIP THEIR
PRODUCTION TO PLACES LIKE
VIETNAM, MALAYSIA, AND OF COURSE
CHINA.
THE 74 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
ALREADY KNOWS THIS.
IT MAY HAVE TO TAKE THAT MESSAGE
THE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS COUNTRY.
AND ALL OF YOU VOTERS IN
GEORGIA -- I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE.
BY SENDING THEM BACK TO
WASHINGTON, YOU WILL SEND A
POWERFUL MESSAGE TO D.C.
RETURN TO THE FAILED POLICIES OF
THE PAST AND WE WILL BLOCK YOU
IN THE SENATE AND FIGHT YOU
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
UNDER BIDEN’S TEAM OF FALSE
PROPHETS WHICH IS REALLY THE OLD
OBAMA TEAM, THE RICH WILL GET
RICHER AS THE WORKING PEOPLE GET
STIFFED ONCE AGAIN WITH
STAGNATING WAGES.
I THINK MORE AND MORE AMERICANS
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN LEARNING
ABOUT WHY INCOME SWORD UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
REPUBLICANS RUNNING IN 2022 AND
2024 -- THEY HAVE AN EASY
ANSWER.
WE KNOW IT WORKS.